on va passer à la caméra cachée de guéyo
tient aujourd'hui greg à louer une
voiture à un particulier et il va devoir
la rendre ça va être un peu
problématique parce qu'il paraît que le
voiture et vous allez voir avec quoi il
revient c'est parti pour mettre en place
sa caméra cachée qui va suivre nous
avons passé une annonce indiquant que
nous souhaitions piéger une personne qui
pourrait me louer une belle voiture on
m'a alors mis en relation avec une
personne du nom de fred qui a accepté de
nous louer son véhicule cette voiture
c'est celle ci donc autant dire une très
belle voiture de sport dont la valeur
est estimée à 40 mille euros je retrouve
donc fret sur le lieu de rendez-vous on
échange nos papiers on discute un peu je
lui remets l'argent correspondant à une
journée de location il me remet les clés
du véhicule
vous m'avez des caves et des rayures ou
déjà pourquoi je n'y aura pas plus de
rigueur que c'est en tout cas la bonne
journée et à demain
le lendemain soir je retrouve fred pour
lui rendre son véhicule sur un an au
lieu de rendez vous nous avons placé des
caméras ils arrivent avant moi et m'a
tant à ya juste un petit détail que je
n'ai pas précisé on ne va pas lui
ramener la voiture qu'il m'a prêté mais
m6 cette partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez bien vous ouais ça va voilà
bah je vais ramener une tour pour vous
remercier
merci merci je vous laisse les clés
voilà pourquoi je laisse les clés et clé
des bavoirs méprenez pas je vais pour
s'aimer posting varie alors pardon à
monsieur oui mais j'ai eu ma voiture à
la votre dire celles que vous postuliez
laquelle audi tt rouge en fait je n'ai
pas dit j'ai un petit soucis j'étais un
restaurant que ma copine et après on
allait faire j'ai prolongé la soirée des
amis fait on s'est retrouvé à à boire un
peu j'étais un peu éméché et du coup
j'ai défoncé la rambarde et du coût de
votre voiture allait enfin elle est
tombée
est tombé à l'eau dans la scène et quoi
avec des bulles et tout c'est assez
lourd et c'est quoi ça ça c'est la
voiture que je vous ramène à la place
cette voiture de substitution du coup je
vais enfin du coup j'ai pris les devants
et je suis passé chez mon nom qui avait
une équivalente à la vôtre est comme ça
vaut ça vous change rien au pied de l
vous plaît pas je dois y aller soit vous
prenez la voiture mais ça n'existait
rien vous devez vous devez vous avez
vous allez est-ce que vous pouvez pas la
tester le produit avant avant de vous
énerver
parce que si on vient la police moi je
vais voir des gros problème j'étais en
état d'ébriété ou illégaux c'est la
voiture dans le mode facile
oui si ça c'est qu'elle est dans l'eau
maintenant et c'est pour ça je peux pas
les aléas la police vous arrange vous
rigolez je vous ai donné un tour je vous
ai donné la voiture vous l'apprenait
vous la prenez pas mes racines et non
pas regarder moi je vais bien vous allez
bien vous avez - vous devez avant de
juger un produit testé leur a donné sa
chance au produit des faux comme tout
cas c'est quoi cette histoire là mais
c'est pas ta merde regard des traces sur
la route et tout bon il ya juste un
petit bémol ce que le plancher prend
l'autre ce que je vous conseille cette
conduire en gautrais ce qui est un petit
souci draps mais devancent la finlande
plastique comment assurer ma femme sont
morts bah vous convient à leurs bottes
moi je dois y aller en tout cas je vous
laisse la voiture vous avez les clés
en plus je vous ai fait une petite tour
pour vous remercier regardez vous le
prenez mal mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] la
trouille et champignons et je mens
voiture bon allez j'y vais c'est pas
grave c'est le coup de foudre
oulouma combat alors c'est quoi cette
histoire là j'ai des amis qui habitent
ici vous voulez qu'on aille au chaud
j'ai donné ma sueur qui coûte 48
nouveaux et monsieur vous dit que
j'étais devancé
fred
écoutez moi ces fausses et pourquoi on
me dit la vérité hier parce que je
voulais vous rend meilleur savez comment
faire quoi cette voiture
mettons nous dans la voiture mais c'est
froid va se maintenant autour de la
kaaba pourquoi vous avez certainement
pas le permis butin mais écoutez moi
quand même nom jean paul ricard à 2000
euros ferme à voir votre permis monsieur
venait
mais merde il est parti avec mes papiers
là je sais pas où ils vous seront faits
nazi je lui dis oui fred c'était une
petite caméra cachée non je suis sérieux
venez je vous vois je vous rend la
voiture c'était une petite blague et je
suis juste un comédien en fait
venez je vous explique tout ça je vous
attends même point de rendez vous
[Musique]
bonsoir
non non non non ouais mais non non tu
veux remercier tout dire je pense à toi
je voudrais
bravo à gatineau tard